hi I'm Maria I love cooking but also I
love food pranks I have more items for
my friends to guess if it's food or
something else
the roads are no smelling the item you
must taste what you pick and sabotage it
is highly encouraged the first item
chocolate or something else one of these
is jelly beans one of them is rocks
depth everyone the royal jelly beans in
a row to be tossed on the green is like
a red herring of sorts mm-hmm I'm
thinking one of them is definitely rocks
this one's multicolored which makes me
think it's more food like but that might
be a red herring they both have like a
very shiny like stones that you would
use in a terrarium yes thing like a fish
tank bass yeah I think that one looks
more like a fish tank bass
I've bought something similar to that
I'll go to the beach a lot I'm Dominican
we know rats when we see them and these
are rocks son I'm gonna come and go with
this I just think you chose wrong okay
thanks fine you can think that I'm going
with this one it sounded like
this is Emily a rock Baba don't believe
a thing daddy yeah I really almost
picked that one because I thought it was
licorice I was trying to throw you off
yeah I'd rather have that at my mouth
and so so you just made me lick a rock
well I'm sure it's been cleaned next we
have gummy bear what's something else
Oh interesting
oh there's something ragged about this
one what you think would make him not a
gummy bear but I'm like too pretty
no one's very clear but at the same time
what I don't know this one is very shiny
this one looks like my usual gummy bear
that I eat they both look like they
could be knockoff gummy bears though
really I mean yeah deception I'm going
for this one
oh girl really yeah I would a hunter
ever sink over though know something
come here I know he looks friendly that
one looks nothing like his arms are like
this he doesn't want to hug you this
armors like that he wants to hook this
one looks sweeter okay and softer say
less I'm a gummy bear connoisseur of
types and I I think that's the gummy
bear this one is beautiful it's almost
too perfect
yeah that's the one I want to eat uh-huh
yeah you're so right I'm gonna choose
that one ready
Cheers delightful yeah look at what I
did like it don't get used to it though
I'm always laughing dude no definitely
not
next we have cookie with something else
left round you have the tiebreaker I
feel hope this one's really hard and you
choose wrong one two three this rock is
beautiful and this brownie looks just as
beautiful yeah there's no way that that
isn't just a rock can you please put the
whole thing in your mouth this one looks
very much like a cookie and we're eating
cookie from the cookie of the house did
you cook you looks like glue that looks
like a brownie that looks like geo Rock
if you just look at it it looks like
lavender sugar crystals with gold edible
paints on top of a triple fudge brownie
this one looks like a wonderful ornament
to go on my bookshelf unless this is
some elaborate sugar cube Oh
how do you think they make that science
science yeah I'm gonna go with this one
I'm seeing a our science project over
there Katie I'm sorry I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna go with this as my final
answer because it's quite clear it looks
so hard yeah hard crystal same time one
two three Oh
pretty hard to do Oh
[Music]
you didn't look ha
yeah really Hey oh yeah buddy hey pretty
good
you should cheers very good here's to
being equal well technically you lost
this one but he we're equal I'm
surprised people can make such realistic
versions of foods I'm not sure what the
purpose of those gummy bears was though
like would you leave a bowl of those out
in your house what are we burning a
brownie yeah that's right we pull
together that's what will bring people
together it's a very pretty cookie I had
for a minute when we first opened it I
was like that's a Jew oh thanks oh I
hate you oh yes
[Music]
[Music]